bonsoir monsieur Roy j'avais dit je suis
très contente c'était énorme comme des
filles là
et partout vous regardez au Québec c'est
énorme il y a maintenant deux gros
points chauds la région de Québec puis
la région de Montréal on va commencer
par Québec
comment va se faire
la communication parce qu'on je pense
que c'est pas exagéré que c'est mal
parti la communication du troisième lien
c'est quoi votre stratégie pour vendre
ça au Québec
mais d'abord je veux je veux quand même
réitérer à quel point je suis heureuse
comme vous le dites le d'accueillir ces
nouvelles fonctions là de la confiance
que mes témoignent le Premier ministre
en confiant un très gros ministère vous
l'avez dit là effectivement donc je
serai seul ministre en titre de ce
ministère des Transports et de la
mobilité durable donc plusieurs défis
prenons le troisième lien vous en parler
je suis en plus une élue de la région de
Québec donc et je lis souvent dit moi
quatre ans j'étais ministre la capitale
nationale et souvent parler du troisième
lien et à chaque fois je répondais et
j'admettais volontiers qu'on a un défi
de communication au sujet de ce beau et
gros projet là qu'on a dans notre
capital national et dans chaudière à
palaches et donc ce sera désormais à moi
de le relever ce défi de communication
pas seulement sur la forme pas seulement
de manière superficielle mais d'essayer
peut-être de mieux expliquer aux gens et
toutes les questions des études les
données tout ça peut-être peut-être
mieux expliquer la façon dont fonctionne
les gros projets d'infrastructures au
gouvernement notamment au ministère des
Transports alors ça va me faire plaisir
de relever ce défi là avec évidemment le
nouveau ministre de la capitale
nationale excellent collègue Jonathan
Jul et le ministre de chaudière à Palace
Bernard drinville qui se retrouve aussi
au cœur de ce dossier là en étant député
de Lévis d'accord vous parlez des études
est-ce que votre priorité ça va être de
dire à tout le monde la machine partout
en haut en bas là il faut rendre public
ce que nous avons on peut pas continuer
à dire attendez attendez de jouer la
carte pour les prochains mois de la
transparence
oui je l'ai dit en campagne on le dit
souvent le les études on s'est engagé à
les rendre public normalement début 2023
mais là évidemment je m'avance ce soir
avec vous mais ça fait quoi deux heures
deux heures et demie que je suis
ministre des Transports et de la
mobilité durable donc je pense tout le
monde va comprendre que je vais prendre
le temps d'aller rencontrer mes équipes
mon sous-ministre associé les gens du
bureau de projet du troisième bien aussi
dans le directeur pour essayer de bien
comprendre le fin fond de parce que
comme ministre de la capitale j’étais
bien au fait du dossier mais c'était pas
mon ministère directement donc désormais
ce sera le mien alors vous avez raison
de dire qu'il y a des questions qui se
posent on va aller au fond de la faire
et moi je serai très transparente et
vous savez je pense depuis 5 ans que je
suis député donc 4 ans ministre j'ai
prouvé à quel point pour moi la
communication est quelque chose
d'important donc je m'engage à
communiquer toujours plus et mieux sur
ce dossier là comme sur les autres le
meilleur marchand et vous est-ce que
vous allez bien travailler vous allez me
dire oui là mais avez-vous bien
travaillé ensemble notamment son projet
tramway qui avait créé des flammèches
avec
d'autres membres du gouvernement logo
oui tout à fait puis ça je l'ai dit à un
moment donné je pense cet été quand je
parlais des collègues à vous des
journalistes des fois à travers l'ajoute
médiatique un peu le jeu des
déclarations à gauche à droite ça peut
des fois donner une impression comme
s'il y avait de la diversité ou quoi que
ce soit il y a pas du tout
et c'est à dire que le fait que bien
avant l'élection de Monsieur Marchal
d'ailleurs nous quand on est arrivé en
2018 c'était dans notre plateforme
électorale l'appui au tramway était là à
notre premier budget en 2019 il y avait
un point 8 milliards pour que le tramway
puisse aller de l'avant on a réglé la
partie du fédéral parce que bon c'était
compliqué un petit peu donc on a
démontré beaucoup de bonnes fois on a
donné les documents aussi les
autorisations administratives
nécessaires pour que le projet continue
d'avancer mais c'est un projet de la
ville de Québec à la différence du
troisième lien qui est un projet du
gouvernement et pour nous il s'inscrit
dans la toile de mobilité durable
vraiment plus vaste qui est le réseau
express de la capitale qui est notre
projet au gouvernement à portée
régionale qui dessert chaudière à
palaches et la capitale nationale donc
pour nous le réseau express de la
capitale c'est ça qui est important on a
besoin la faute du tra du troisième lien
des voies réservées sur la rive nord des
voies réservées sur la Rive-Sud et le
tramway en fait partie donc mais
évidemment là comme le reste je vais
prendre le temps de d'approfondir les
choses avec le maire avec l'équipe de la
ville de Québec puisque c'est un projet
de la ville là un feu à partir du là il
est déjà commencé le feu à éteindre
c'est le pont tunnel Louis paulite
Lafontaine à Montréal et le problème
plus global de la circulation des
bouchons à Montréal tu es pouvant être
souvent on entendait à les gens de
Montréal comprennent pas au Québec aussi
mais là ça atteint un point inouï il y
aura peut-être des mesures d'urgence à
prendre donc est-ce que vous allez ce
que vous engagez d'abord passer beaucoup
plus de temps à Montréal pour comprendre
les enjeux ligne bleue
remonté etc
oui absolument il y a de très très gros
projets et enjeux à Montréal vous l'avez
dit puis vous avez raison de nommer le
tunnel Hippolyte la fontaine parce que à
court terme là c'est le premier défi qui
va se poser le 31 octobre commence les
travaux on en a pour une certaine
période de temps comme vous savez mais
il y a déjà plusieurs mesures là encore
je vais évidemment rencontrer les
équipes et tout ça et puis voir par
moi-même mais c'est un dossier qu'on
suivait tous de près au gouvernement
j'en ai parlé avec monsieur bernardel
qui était mon prédécesseur il y a déjà
plusieurs mesures qui ont été mises en
place pour essayer au mieux évidemment
il y a pas de miracle à faire là ces
travaux-là doivent se faire mais pour
essayer au mieux d'offrir des
alternatives aux gens de Montréal pour
offrir des alternatives de en transport
collectif c'est le meilleur accès les
réductions de tarifs et tout ça pour
convaincre les gens de renoncer autant
que possible à leur voiture et prendre
du transport collectif mais on va
s'adapter ici ça va être quelque chose
qui va être corset on peut l'admettre
mais on va être très pragmatique et puis
on va s'adapter on va être résilient on
va voir s'il faut faire d'autres mesures
on va les faire mais on a cette réalité
là avec laquelle on n'a pas le choix
proposé de la nécessité de ces travaux
là dans le tunnel je comprends que vous
dites fait quelques heures effectivement
qu'un ministre arrive on peut pas
s'attendre vous avez pas tout lu puis
vous avez pas tout rencontrer mais c'est
engagement de venir beaucoup plus
souvent à Montréal il va falloir passer
beaucoup plus de temps que vous ne le
faisiez évidemment compte tenu de vos
responsabilités que vous aviez là
mais oui tout à fait et puis je m'en
suis pas caché moi j'avais laissé savoir
au Premier ministre que j'étais tout à
fait prête à céder mes fonctions de
ministre de la capitale nationale a des
collègues j'ai 8 excellents collègues
dans la capitale et là c'est le député
de Charlesbourg le ministre Jonathan
Julien qui en est hérité je vais
travailler avec lui mais évidemment ça
me libère effectivement là puis je vais
continuer de m'investir beaucoup dans
capitaine nationale je demande une élu à
Québec la question pas là et il y a des
gros dossiers à Québec aussi mais oui la
grande région métropolitaine on parle de
Montréal mais je voudrais la grande
région métropolitaine parce qu'on a des
projets Rive-Nord et ceux
d'éventuellement peut-être des choses en
outai on a beaucoup de projets
d'infrastructure en transport au
gouvernement si je résume la journée là
je parle à la vis première ministre si
je résume la journée en disant monsieur
le goût donne encore plus de
responsabilité à son cercle rapproché là
les puis vous faites partie de ça des
ministres qui ont des grosses
responsabilités il y a quand même 10
personnes nouvelles qui amènent une
nouvelle sensibilité notamment
sur l'immigration avec Madame Frechette
on annonçant on sent on sent un désir
d'apaisement et Monsieur fitzgerbin à
Montréal on sent une main tendue aussi
en disant on peut pas gouverner sans
avoir une place pour Montréal est-ce que
je résume bien l'objectif de la journée
absolument j'aime bien votre résumé je
vous dirais vous êtes apaisé moi je
dirais rassembler la main tendue le dès
la soirée électorale le 3 octobre le
Premier ministre est à Québec et dans
son discours il a dit une campagne
électorale c'est normal ça divise parce
qu'on a chacun nos idées bon au débat et
tout ça mais une fois que le résultat
est tombé une fois que les Québécois ont
fait leur choix quel que soit le parti
politique qui forme le gouvernement le
Premier ministre et l'équipe du
gouvernement a le devoir de rassembler
puis de miser sur ce qui nous unit or
les priorités de notre gouvernement
quand on parle d'éducation de santé
d'économie verte transition énergétique
environnement
identité culture je pense moi que ce
sont des priorités qui vont rejoindre
aussi un grand nombre de députés pas
nécessairement seulement de la CAQ donc
à l'Assemblée nationale on va tabler sur
ces priorités là communes sur les choses
qui sont importantes pour nous comme
députés du Québec et moi je vais le
faire dans mes dossiers en transport
aussi on a des collègues dans diverses
régions des projets en transport il y en
a dans toutes les régions il y a les
gros gros projets ensuite il y a ce
qu'on appelle souvent la voirie locale
autiste un ministère qui est très
régionalisé qui a des incidents c'est
très locales donc je vais travailler
avec tous les députés le quel que soit
le parti politique on va se reparler des
dossiers plus à fond au cours des
prochains mois Geneviève Guilbaud
nouvelle ministre des Transports
vice-première ministre merci à la
prochaine merci à vous au revoir bonne
soirée